Trascrizione: Anna Cristiana Minoli
“Qui invece, vedete, ci sta un...”
“Pure a me uno di questi, eh!”
Scusa, tu non sei femmina!”
“E questi?”
“Tu non sei femmina!”
(Applausi)
Mi avete riconosciuto?
Ero quello che faceva
la televendita di pasta
(Risate)
Mentre quell’altra
che ci teneva a ricordarmi
le regole del genere
per indossare un braccialetto
era mia sorella.
Direte voi:
è forse questa la vendetta suprema
nel conflitto tra fratelli
tu lo dirai pure a mamma,
ma io ci faccio un TEDTalk.
(Risate)
Forse!
No, in realtà questa è
una testimonianza su videocassetta
di qualcuno che mi ricorda da piccolo
cos’è da maschi e cos’è da femmina.
Evidentemente facevo un po’ di confusione.
E vi assicuro che non è
l’unica testimonianza che ho.
Quindi immaginate quanto potesse succedere
lontano dai riflettori.
Io avevo sette anni,
mia sorella ne aveva tre,
e lei non stava facendo nient’altro
che trovare un pretesto
per avere il braccialetto per sé.
Però lo faceva con un argomento
potentissimo per i bambini.
I bambini non vanno d’accordo
con le regole:
quando uno prova a dirgli
questo non si fa,
si fa così, ci si comporta così,
è tutto un, “E perché? E perché no?”
C’è solo un un insieme di regole,
che i bambini accettano
quasi senza proteste:
le regole di genere,
da maschi e da femmine.
Quante regole di genere conosciamo?
Un sacco, ovviamente,
le più classiche: il rosa, l’azzurro.
il calcio, la danza,
le costruzioni, le bambole.
Potrei continuare all’infinito.
Non le abbiamo mai studiate
e le sappiamo a memoria.
Sapremmo dire ad occhi chiusi
cosa ci compete in base al nostro genere.
E ci sono alcune cose che sono
anche abbastanza assurde,
se mi permettete.
Il fiore: l’elemento fiore, stelo, petali.
è da maschi o da femmine?
L’animale squalo è più da maschio
o più da femmine?
La seta? Più da maschi o più da femmine?
Seta, non feta,
perché nelle prove si sentiva feta.
Se trovaste una grafia tondeggiante,
pensereste che l’ha scritto
una donna o un uomo?
Potrei continuare all’infinito.
Crescendo, iniziamo a muoverci
in un sistema intricatissimo
di norme e di ruoli, che invadono
tutti gli aspetti della nostra vita.
I vestiti, gli studi, i lavori.
si arriva ai comportamenti,
gli interessi, le passioni,
ciò di cui parliamo, come ne parliamo,
e poi si arriva anche ai sentimenti,
alle emozioni.
Quali emozioni dovremmo vivere,
come dovremmo esprimerle.
Chi è più razionale,
chi è più sensibile.
A chi è concesso piangere, e chi invece,
per carattere è più idoneo
a prendere decisioni e a guidare.
Quindi cresciamo con questa serie
di regole che ci vengono trasmesse
in molto modi.
Ce lo insegnano i nostri genitori,
lo confermano i nostri compagni di classe,
gli amichetti.
E più o meno esplicitamente
viene rappresentato dal mondo
attorno a noi,
Raramente ci viene data
una spiegazione di queste regole.
Sicuramente non una spiegazione razionale,
logica.
Converrete con me, perché non c’è.
eppure vi aderiamo lo stesso.
Perché non lo so.
Immagino che quando siamo piccoli,
intenti a costruire la nostra identità.
la nostra personalità,
troviamo nelle regole di genere,
un supporto, una guida.
un libretto di istruzioni che alla fine
sembra abbastanza chiaro
e condiviso da tutti, e noi ci affidiamo.
Un percorso già tracciato,
una strada, un binario.
che dopotutto è rassicurante.
E noi ci incamminiamo.
Crescendo però, ci rendiamo conto
che non è soltanto una guida.
Sono vere e proprie regole.
E le regole, scusate la giurisprudenza,
per loro natura
se sono violate, comportano una pena.
E in questo caso, la pena è l’esclusione.
E noi abbiamo bisogno
di appartenere ad un gruppo.
Noi dobbiamo essere
membri di una comunità.
A partire dalla nostra famiglia,
per arrivare alla nostra cerchia di amici,
di conoscenti, di colleghi.
È terribile sentirsi esclusi,
sentirsi estranei.
In particolare è terribile
se questa esclusione deriva da chi siamo,
da come siamo fatti.
Tu non sei femmina,
perché non fai cose da maschi?
Quando un bambino si sente dire
una cosa del genere, si sente colpevole,
come se avesse rotto un patto,
“Scusate non lo faccio più,
mi sono sbagliato.”
E poche cose temiamo da bambini
come la vergogna.
Gli occhi degli altri puntati su di noi
che abbiamo commesso un errore,
quale esso sia, non importa.
Poi cresciamo e magari quella vergogna
iniziamo a chiamarla
senso di inadeguatezza.
Però comunque, la evitiamo come possiamo.
E quindi crescendo,
quel binario su cui ci eravamo incamminati
si assottiglia sempre di più
e assomiglia sempre di più a una fune tesa
sulla quale camminare in equilibrio.
E se cadiamo,
ecco quel senso di inadeguatezza
ci assale nuovamente.
A ricordarci di mantenere l’equilibrio
ci sono gli altri, ci sono le norme,
la minaccia dell’esclusione.
Quindi noi ci mettiamo lì e ci adeguiamo,
conformiamo i nostri comportamenti.
Cambiamo anche
il nostro modo di pensare.
A tal punto che a un certo punto
non servirà nessuno a ricordarci
di mantenere l’equilibrio.
Lo faremo noi in automatico,
per noi stessi.
Volevo iniziare questo TED, questa sera,
con un altro incipit.
Volevo confessarvi
che faccio la pipì seduto.
Poi mi sono detto,
“Pierluca, ma veramente vuoi iniziare
il primo TEDTalk della tua vita
con l’immagine di te che fai la pipì?”
Però scusate,
anche sulla pipì siamo riusciti
a mettere regole di genere.
Una cosa fisiologica,
naturale, che facciamo tutti
eppure i maschi la fanno in piedi
e le femmine la fanno sedute.
Non importa che sia più comodo,
più igienico farla seduti.
E quindi io, per un periodo,
della mia vita --
questa è la confessione --
ho alzato la tavoletta del bagno
dopo averla usata
perché sia mai che la persona
che veniva dopo di me
potesse credere che io la facevo seduto.
Che vergogna, che onta!
Per carità!
Vi ho regalato quindi un quadretto
più familiare di questo della pipì,
più divertente, con me e mia sorella,
però non per questo meno intimo.
Perché sin da piccolo,
ho iniziato a segnarmi
ogni appunto che mi veniva fatto,
e che marcava la differenza
tra me e i miei amici maschi.
E temevo
tutto ciò che invece mi faceva
assomigliare alle mie amiche femmine.
È così terribile,
un lavoro costante ed estenuante,
quello di adeguarsi,
di guardarsi dall’esterno,
esaminarsi, correggersi.
Assicurarsi che tutto
sia in linea con le aspettative.
È una cosa devastante per un bambino.
Perché vuol dire reprimersi.
Vuol dire censurarsi.
Poi si cresce,
e le differenze tra i maschi e le femmine
si fanno più nette.
Si allunga la lista delle regole.
E soprattutto diventa un po’ più nervoso
il modo con cui ti viene fatto notare
che stai sbagliando.
Tu sei maschio,
perché fai cose da femmina?
Pensate all’esempio molto banale,
molto semplice
di un uomo che decide
di uscire di casa con la gonna.
Immaginatevi per strada,
persone che sicuramente lo guardano.
lo additano, lo deridono.
È un pezzo di stoffa,
tagliato in una certa maniera,
che peraltro conosciamo tutti.
Però è fortissima questa reazione.
E mi chiedo:
Perché?
È proprio necessaria questa insistenza?
Bisogna per forza rimarcare
in maniera così forte le regole di genere
se queste sono la spontanea conseguenza,
la naturale conseguenza
del nostro essere maschio e femmina.
un complemento che stava lì già da prima.
Crescendo, questo senso di inadeguatezza
che mi ha accompagnato per anni,
e che mi ha appesantito per anni,
ha ceduto il posto ad un’altra cosa:
la consapevolezza che ci vengono insegnati
limiti e non possibilità.
Ci viene detto,
“Tu puoi fare quello che ti pare,
puoi essere chi vuoi,
purché nel recinto dell’essere maschi,
che mi rendo conto
è un recinto di privilegio.
Però è sempre un recinto.
Limiti e non possibiità.
Sin da bambini, quando ci viene chiesto,
“Cosa vuoi dare da grande?”
anche su quello, anche sui sogni,
e le aspirazioni di un bambino,
abbiamo imparato
ad applicare i filtri del genere.
Mi piacerebbe, questa sera, qua,
salire su questo palco,
chiudere questa serata raccontandovi
che io me ne frego dei ruoli di genere
che sono un ganzo,
che dalla mattina quando mi sveglio
alla sera quando vado a dormire,
sono 100% autenticamente me stesso.
Me piacesse!
Ma non posso.
Purtroppo non posso,
perché è troppo vivo in me
il ricordo del tempo speso
e della fatica investita
nel cercare di adeguarmi,
nel cercare di colmare la distanza
tra me e i miei coetanei maschi,
evitando, reprimendo tutte quelle cose
che per me erano spontanee, naturali,
e che però quella distanza
la aumentavano, la creavano.
Però ho capito una cosa.
Che le regole di genere
non sono un problema mio.
Sono un problema di altri.
Ho deciso di vederne le possibilità,
e non i limiti.
E quindi mi si è aperto un mondo
di risorse infinite,
la possibilità di esprimere
la mia personalità in ogni direzione.
Poter scegliere da un menu completo
e non da una serie di cose
preselezionate da altri per me.
Per una vita,
ho odiato la mia voce.
Troppo poco maschile,
troppo poco grave, profonda.
Ogni tanto faccio gli acuti.
Quando qualcuno mi chiama al telefono
e non sa chi c’è dall’altra parte
mi dicono, “Salve signora.”
E io dico, “Mi dica.”
Perciò, odiando la mia voce
ho evitato che venisse registrata
in qualsiasi video o audio
che poi fosse reso pubblico.
Capite che con i social
diventa un po’ limitante.
E non è che non avessi cose da dire
o che fossi timido.
Tutt’altro.
Poi è arrivato l’anno assurdo
che è appena passato,
che ha ribaltato un po’ tutte le regole,
che ci ha chiesto di guardare le cose
da un’altra prospettiva.
Io mi sono detto, “Sai che c’è?”
Ci provo.
Speriamo che non si accorgano
che non ho la voce molto maschile.
Speriamo che si concentrino
su ciò che ho da dire.
E quindi ho iniziato
a creare contenuti su Instagram.
Peraltro,
adeguarsi, conformarsi richiedono
un dispendio di energie enorme.
Una volta che liberiamo quelle energie
possiamo investirle
in ciò che ci piace fare
e farlo bene.
Magari.
In quest’anno meditativo
che abbiamo appena passato,
ci siamo guardati da vicino,
abbiamo riflettuto su tante cose,
ognuno sulle sue.
Però ecco,
possiamo anche recuperare un rapporto
un po’ più intimo con noi stessi.
E qui mi rivolgo agli uomini.
Proviamo a conoscere
la nostra versione di maschile.
Proviamo a entrare in contatto
con quella parte più autentica di noi,
libera da stereotipi,
liberi da ruoli preimpostati.
Facciamolo con l’obiettivo
di fiorire come individui.
E attenzione,
io non sto dicendo questa cosa
in una direzione.
Il mio discorso non vuole invitarvi
ad abbracciare la vostra femminilità.
Perché onestamente,
non vuol dire niente questa frase.
Non vuol dire nulla.
Perché ci fa ripiombare
in un binarismo di genere che no ha senso.
Io che sono maschio,
decido di fare una cosa da femmine.
Che bravo!
Ho abbracciato la mia femminilità. No!
Perché esistono abbastanza
versioni di maschile
quanti maschi esistono sulla terra.
Perché noi possiamo riscrivere
la definizione di mascolinità,
se quella comune ci va stretta.
Possiamo decidere di scendere
da quella fune tesa.
e tracciare il nostro percorso.
Per farlo abbiamo bisogno
di guardarci con occhi diversi,
interessati a conoscerci.
Occhi curiosi,
che si facciano anche delle domande,
che si chiedano:
Chi siamo? Cosa ci fa stare bene?
Cosa ci limita invece?
Avete mai evitato di fare qualcosa
perché era da femmine?
E avete mai fatto qualcosa soltanto perché
era ciò che ci si aspettava da voi
in quanto uomini?
Avete mai limitato l’espressione
della vostra emotività
per paura di sembrare troppo poco virili?
Sapreste dire
dove finisce la vostra identità
e dove iniziano
tutti i complementi legati al genere
che abbiamo appreso
e portato con noi sin da piccoli?
Se faceste la pipì seduti, lo direste
con tanta tranquillità o lo nascondereste?
Basta Pierluca di parlare di pipì,
questo è un problema tutto tuo.
Basta. Basta pipì.
Quando si parla di genere, pensiamo subito
alle lotte e alle conquiste
che hanno fatto le donne negli anni
e che stanno facendo tutt’ora.
Pensiamo sia la loro lotta.
Noi possiamo trovarla giusta,
possiamo fare il tifo, supportarle,
agevolarla se possibile,
ma non capiamo che riguarda anche noi.
Che è una crescita collettiva.
Perché anche a noi viene data
un’unica versione di maschile.
Anche a noi viene detto
che c’è solo un modo giusto
per essere uomini.
Veri uomini.
Riscrivendo la definizione di maschile,
libera da stereotipi,
contribuiamo anche a quella lotta.
E non è troppo tardi
per mettere in discussione
ciò che abbiamo imparato sul genere.
che sin da piccoli
abbiamo messo in pratica.
Cose che magari
abbiamo anche portato avanti,
di cui siamo diventati fautori.
Infatti non sono stato
completamente sincero con voi,
questa sera.
perché il video che vi ho mostrato
racconta solo una parte della storia,
quella in cui vengo accusato
da mia sorella
di essere troppo poco maschio,
perché indossavo il braccialetto.
Però poco prima,
mi ero macchiato delle stesse colpe,
mi ero fatto portatore
di stereotipi simili.
“E ci sta tutto il buon sapore della...
E qua dietro ci sta pure la cottura...
ma come sempre, voi lo sapete
donne carissime.
Qui invece vedete,
ci sta un...”
“pure a me uno di questi eh...
Scusa, tu non sei femmina!
“E questi...”
“Tu non sei femmina!”
“Zitta!”
(Risate)
“Però tu non sei femmina!”
“Buono, dopo te lo do.
E questi sono i diavolini rigati.
Non ho ancora capito perché diavolini,
però sono molto buoni.”
(Risate)
Non ho ancora capito
cosa siano i diavolini
(Applausi)
Anni e anni di ricerca
nel settore della pasta,
e delle televendite, ma niente.
Chi è che fa la spesa a casa?
Le donne.
Chi è che cucina?
Le donne
Mia sorella mi stava pagando
con la stessa moneta.
E me lo meritavo.
Mi stava bene.
E poi come deve reagire un uomo
quando una donna lo contesta?
Contestazione giusta o non giusta che sia.
Azzittendola.
Però con un acuto almeno!
Grazie.
(Applausi)